PROFESSOR:
Propositional operators
play a basic role in the
design of digital circuitry,
and we're going to illustrate
that in the section
by designing a little
binary addition circuit.
So let's begin with a review
of binary notation and addition
in binary.
So the way binary
works is like decimal.
Except instead of
using powers of 10,
you're using powers of 2.
So here is the binary
representation of the number
39.
The way to understand that
is this is the ones place.
That's the twos place.
That's the fours place.
So 1 plus 2 plus 4 is 7.
Then this is the eighth
place with nothing,
this is the 16th
place with something,
and this is the 32 place with 1.
So we get 32 to 7, and get 39.
Likewise, the binary
representation of 28 is 011100.
I'll let you check how that
works with contributing 1, 2,
4, 8, 16, and 32.
And finally, let's add
these two numbers in binary.
Now, binary addition works
just like decimal addition
except that the only
numbers are ones and zeros
so that when you get 1 plus
1, you have to carry 1.
Let's do that.
So 1 plus 0 is 1.
That fills in the first column.
Now we have another
1 plus 0 is 1.
That's fine.
Now we have a 1 plus 1.
And that's going do a 0 here
and contribute a carry of 1
to the next column.
Now, the next
column has two ones.
So it becomes a
0 and contributes
to another carrying.
Now we have two ones.
We get a 0 and
contribute another carry.
And now we have two ones,
and we finally get a 1 0.
So this is the binary
representation of the sum,
and you can check that this
is 1 plus 2 is 3 plus 64.
So the answer should be 67.
And you can check that it is.
So that's how binary
addition works.
So now let's try to design
a bit of circuitry using
digital logic signals of 0
and 1, which will do addition.
And so we're going to try
to design a little six bit
binary addition circuit.
So I'm going to have
as inputs, the six
digits of the first binary
number-- a 5 down through a 0
and then the second
binary number.
Let's call it b 0 through b 5.
So these are two binary numbers
that are six digits long,
and I'm going to add them up
by thinking of a 1 as a 0 or 1
signal. a 0 is a 0 1
signal. b 0 is a 0 1 signal.
And these can be
transmitted down wires
into some boxes that contain
digital operators that
will cause the right
signals to come out.
And what we want
to come out of here
is the possibly seven
digit representation
of their binary sum.
So d 0 is the sum of a 0 and
b 0-- the lower digit possibly
with carry and so on.
And then c 5 if the sum
of two six digit numbers
runs to seven digits,
which it might
as we saw in the
previous example,
then c 5 would become
1, otherwise 0.
So this is the specification.
I want a and b to come in,
and I want their binary sum
to come out as d's with a
high order c if need be.
Now, the way I'm
going to do that is
it's clear that the behavior
of the inputs for a and b,
which produced the lower
digit, might produce a carry,
and that carry has to be
transmitted to the next column
if it exists.
So I'm going to need a
wire that sends a 0 1
signal from this box over to
that one that carries 0 or 1
and likewise for
all of the others.
So this is the kind of basic
structure of my binary addition
circuit.
This is called a ripple
carry organization.
It's mimicking exactly the way
that we added up to two numbers
column by column, possibly
propagating carry of 0 or 1--
or really a carry of just
1 to the next column.
And I've got all the wires
in place that I need.
What we need to do is
design the digital circuitry
that's in those boxes.
Well, this box is
different from the others
because it's only
got two inputs.
All the others
have three inputs.
So the three input boxes, we'll
call full adders and the two
input boxes a half an adder.
And the specification
of a half an adder,
again, is that the output is
the binary representation of a 0
plus b 0.
So it's a two digit binary
representation-- never
be bigger than 2 because
there's only two numbers.
The output of a full adder
is it gets three inputs
in this case-- b 1, a 1.
And the carry, c 0.
And it produces the
binary representation
of the sum of those
three numbers, which
is a two digit binary
representation that
might be anything from 0 to 3.
OK.
Well, let's start
with the easy case.
What's a half adder?
Well, a half adder,
again, has inputs b and a,
and it's supposed
to produce as output
the binary representation
of b plus a.
So d is the lower digit
in the zeros place,
and c is the high order
digit, namely the twos place.
Well, what does that look like?
Well, here's the circuit.
This is the digital
designer symbol
for an exclusive [INAUDIBLE]
gate that returns.
So d is going to be the
exclusive or of a and b
according to this
pictorial diagram.
Notice I'm using
this colon colon
equal symbol which is
convenient as a reminder
that I'm defining the
thing on the left.
You could replace it
by equal, but it's
informative to realize that
it's not an equality that you've
proved or that some derivation
of the two interesting things
are proven to be equal,
but rather that I'm just
defining what the d is.
This output d is
defined to be a XOR b.
And likewise, this
is an AND gate.
So the output c a AND b.
And let's check that.
The low order digit is
definitely the [INAUDIBLE] sum,
XOR of a and b.
And when is there a carry?
Well, the only way
there's a carry
is when the value is 2, in which
case the output c would be 1
and d would be 0.
And that's exactly
when both a and b
are 1, that is c is a and b.
So that's a half adder.
That was easy.
Well, a full adder
looks like this.
It's a little bit
more complicated,
and I'm going to write out
the equations without trying
to justify them completely.
But I need a name in
order to describe this
with propositional operators.
I need a name for
that important signal.
Call it s, which
is what we were not
calling it in the previous one.
But now this is a half
adder with inputs a
and b and outputs s, which
is a XOR b and another output
here, which we know is
just going to be a and b.
OK.
How do I express this set
of connections as formulas?
Well, first of all, s is the
output of this first half
adder, which is a XOR b.
OK.
The output d I get
by taking s, and it's
the first output of the
second half adder, which
means it's c in XOR or s.
That's easy.
And what about c out?
Well, c out is getting-- this
is an OR gate by the way.
So c out is going to be
an OR of what comes out
of this half adder,
which is c in
and c s and OR with the output
of this half adder, which
is just a and b.
So there are a
bunch of equations
that completely characterize
the structure of this little bit
of digital logic and how it
is wired up and fits together.
Now, let's go back to describing
our ripple carry circuit
of what was going on here.
Now that we have the equations
that characterize the behavior
of these full adders
and half adders,
I can explain to you what the
formulas are for all of these
outputs-- the c's and the d's.
And that goes as follows.
So the first one, looking at
this half adder with a 0, b 0
coming in and c
0, d 0 coming out,
I know that d 0 is a 0 XOR
b 0 and c 0 is a 0 AND b0.
That's just that the formulas
that we have for the half
adder when the inputs are a 0
and b 0 and I call the outputs
b 0 and c 0.
Now, the more general
case of the full adder--
what's coming in
here is an a and a b
with the same
subscript-- a i and b i.
And what's coming out is the
ith digit of the binary sum, d i
and the carry c i.
And I could describe those
just by using the formulas
for the full adder.
So what it means
is that I'm going
to introduce a new
convening variable,
s i, which I'm going to
define to be a i or XOR b i.
D i is then going to
be c i minus 1-- the
carry from the previous
place-- XOR with s i.
And the new carry,
c i, is going to be
the output of the first half
adder, which is c i minus 1
AND s i or the output of
the first half adder, which
is a i and b i.
So the point is that I've
just taken the wiring
and translated it into
equations like this,
and you can see how these
equations might be better
to use than the particular
way that you drew
the picture with all
the wires connected
because the logical
behavior of the circuit
doesn't depend on
how it's laid out.
It just depends on these logical
connectives between the values
of these different variables.